some of you have been homeless some of
you have risked the rejection of your
families many of you have lain awake at
night wondering how on earth you were
going to support your parents and your
kids and many of you know what it's like
to live not just month-to-month or day
to day but meal to meal let me tell you
you you should never ever be embarrassed
by those struggles
you should never view your challenges as
a disadvantage
instead it's important for you to
understand that your experience facing
and overcoming adversity is actually one
of your biggest advantages life will put
many obstacles in your path you'll have
unreasonable bosses and difficult
clients and patience you'll experience
illnesses and losses crises and setbacks
that will come out of nowhere and knock
you off your feet keep moving through
the pain keep moving I've always felt a
deep sense of obligation to make the
biggest impact possible with this
incredible platform so I took on issues
that were personal to me now some folks
criticize my choices for not being bold
enough but these were my choices my
issues and I decided to tackle them in a
way that felt most authentic to me in a
way that was both substantive and
strategic but also fun and hopefully
inspiring so I immersed myself I worked
with Congress on legislation engaged
speeches to CEOs military generals
Hollywood executives but I also worked
to ensure that my efforts would resonate
with kids and families I planted a
garden and hula hooped on the White
House lawn with kids I did some mom
dancing on TV and at the end of the day
by staying true to the me I've always
known I found that this journey has been
incredibly freeing because no matter
what happened I had the peace of mind of
knowing that all of the chatter
the name-calling the doubting all of it
was just noise it did not define me it
didn't change who I was and most
importantly it couldn't hold me back I
have learned that as long as I hold fast
to my beliefs and values and follow my
own moral compass then the only
expectations I need to leave live up to
are my own you just watched two amazing
clips of Michelle Obama take the next
three minutes to sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]